a murder trial will start this morning
for a former Texas police officer
accused of killing her unarmed neighbor
amber Geyer shot both of John in his
apartment last September after Geiger
claims she mistook John's apartment for
her own John's family spoke to Omar
Villafranca in their only broadcast TV
interview Omar is at the Frank Crowley
courthouse in Dallas Omar what can we
expect today
good morning opening arguments begin
here later this morning here's some
basic facts of the case Geiger and Jean
did not know each other but they lived
one floor apart and we're expecting the
Geiger's lawyers to basically argue that
she acted in self-defense now 911 former
officer told the dispatcher I thought it
was my apartment nearly 20 times both of
John's parents Bertha and Alison travel
from their native st. Lucia to Dallas
for this trial I spoke with the pair who
say they're nervous that justice will
not be served it's dependent on so many
human beings it's dependent on the jury
it's dependent on a prosecution is
dependent on a defense it's dependent on
several things so you can't control
things that I can't control so on the
one hand as a woman of faith I leave it
to God to judge but as a mom but as a
mom and as a human being I know that
humans do not always act as God once
Geiger faces life in prison if she's
convicted of murder if she's found not
guilty she will walk now John's father
says after a long process he is ready to
forgive Geiger but as for his mother she
says he's not quite there yet
Gail yeah you can still see the pain
thank you very much Omar